E
MOMENTUM THAN IT DESERVES.
>> Shannon: THANK YOU,
DR. COLLINS.
ISRAELI HAS MOVED FORCES TO THE
GAZA BORDER AS IT PREPARES WITH
POTENTIAL GROUND INCURSION WITH
HAMAS.
TREY YINGST JOINS US LIVE FROM
THE GAZA-ISRAEL BORDER AS THE
VIOLENCE THREATENS TO ESCALATE
INTO A FULL-BLOWN WAR.
GOOD EVENING, TREY.
>> SHANNON, GOOD EVENING.
FIGHTING IS CONTINUING TONIGHT
BETWEEN ISRAEL AND GAZA AS THE
DEATH TOLL IS RISING.
TONIGHT, THE ISRAELI AIR FORCE
IS BOMBING TARGETS THROUGHOUT
THE GAZA STRIP AND EARLIER IN
THE EVENING, THE ARTILLERY UNITS
BEHIND ME WERE FIRING SHELLS AT
HAMAS AND SLACK JIHAD POSITIONS.
THE DAMAGE DONE TO GAZA IN THE
PAST 24 SET BACK YEARS THIS.
LEVEL OF CONFLICT HASN'T BEEN
SEEN IN THE REGION SINCE
OPERATION PROTECTIVE EDGE IN
201.
MORE THAN 125 PALESTINIANS HAVE
BEEN KILLED SO FAR.
AND HUNDREDS MORE INJURED.
31 OF THE DEAD ARE CHILDREN.
ON THE ISRAELI SIDE THE DEATH
TOLL REACHED 9 PEOPLE TODAY.
THE ISRAELI MILITARY SAID THAT
MORE THAN 2,000 ROCKETS HAVE
BEEN FIRED FROM GAZA INTO ISRAEL
SINCE MONDAY.
THE CROSS BORDER VIOLENCE IS NO
LONGER FOCUSED ONLY HERE AND NOW
ACROSS THE REGION.
TODAY 11 PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN
THE WEST BANK DURING CLASHES
WITH ISRAELI DEFENSE FORCES.
PROTESTS ALSO ERUPTED ALONG THE
LEBANESE AND JORDANIAN BORDERS
WITH ISRAEL LEADING TO THE DEATH
OF AT LEAST ONE PERSON THERE IS
A REAL SENSE ON THE GROUND THAT
THINGS ARE UNRAVELING EXTREMELY
QUICKLY AS PRIME MINISTER
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU SAID TODAY
HE'S NOT DROP WITH THE RESPONSE
FROM ISRAEL TOWARDS HAMAS AS THE
GROUP CONTINUES THIS EVENING TO
FIRE ROBERTS.
SHANNON?
>> S